krachten auf instagram folgen und rebell
45 jetzt auf instagram grün sind die
harmlosen hast du gerade gesagt genau wo
fangen wir mit den harmlosen an
woher hast du diese wortgewandtheit ich
habe eine schule aufgepasst ich war gut
in deutsch
ich bin mit sechs jahren nach
deutschland gekommen und war trotzdem
auf dem gymnasium ich war ehrgeizig habe
die deutsche sprache gelernt war am
dichten boot und lernt entwickelt sich
weiter wie ist viele bücher gelesen
definitiv so kommuniziert wie deine
frage warum bist du so selbstbewusst
weil ich ein rebell bin und wenn ein
rebell keine starke persönlichkeit ist
wer dann meine freunde selbstbewusst ich
denke die situation im leben die einen
prägen daran wächst man und die machen
einen selbstbewusst und wenn man diese
geschichte hat wie ich dass ich einfach
nach deutschland gekommen und auf neue
umgebung neue freunde neue sprache
das sind sachen dann wo man menschlich
wächst und ich denke das wirkt sich auch
auf das selbstbewusstsein aus
wie kam es zu auf den namen rebell ich
denke es spiegelt meine persönlichkeit
stärker wieder nur noch route aber auch
nur 303 grün rot ist das immer so
manchmal fallen am meer roter rain
einmal mehr rot
okay aber letzte grüne frage ist was
macht dich bei deinem fans so beliebt
ich denke man kann sich mit mir
identifizieren die sachen die ich sage
sind sehr realitätsnah ich denke das ist
ein argument warum warum ich die
hörerschaft habe die scheibe und ich bin
sehr komplett wenn man jetzt nur auf rap
stehe ich bin ein sehr kompletter rapper
ein sehr kompletter msc ich ganz schnell
und langsam retten dies kann ich keine
liebeslieder machen ich kann
straßen niedermachen ich kann themen
songs machen ich kann alles machen
ok und du hast aber was ist was ich
festgestellt habe dass auch viele
weibliche fans ja komisch mal jakob
nicht alle anderen reparieren scheiße
aus nein das nicht aber ich mache auch
gefühlvolle songs auch sachen mit
message die frauen nehmen er sowas
deswegen das ist mein cousin gabriel der
schwergewichtsboxer pkw noch nicht über
den weg gelaufen vielleicht auch bei
ihnen gibt es nicht schlag mich nicht so
neueste boxster rechte ist richtig
brutal ok 19 jahre alt null niederlagen
profitieren schon okay das ist kein spaß
deswegen gibt es facebook seite schöne
grüße bist du rapper geworden weil es
für den profi fußball nicht gerecht nein
weil ich ja wirklich mit der musik ich
habe mich da rein gesteigert erst als
als das fußball ging schon durch war
aber ich kann mir sagt ich kann sagen
warum ich kein fußballprofi geworden bin
weil auch das hat einen grund ich war
einfach nicht disziplin diszipliniert
genug dass auch gerade wenn man auch in
deutschland fußballer werden ist sehr
wichtig in brasilien gibt es immer noch
viele menschen die einfach ein bisschen
bisschen erste menschen mannschaft
schaffen
obwohl die
eigene mitspieler verprügelt und was
weiß ich aber in deutschland musste
wirklich hoch diszipliniert sein damit
du da oben auch landen kann
das hatte ich nicht beim reibt man gar
nicht sein
beim rap bei gewissen rap arten bist du
nix ja sogar besser
dann bist du der rüpel-rapper wie seit
neuestem so das gangsta rap nicht
langsam auf definitiv gangsta rap ist
wird langsam auf deswegen an alle
gangster rapper versucht euch mal ein
bisschen anders und lasst euch mal was
neues einfallen habe ich meinen weg
schon gefunden
ich wünsche euch viel glück wenn nicht
schon fast viertel
ich bin ripper und wenn dann über bette
rapper okay bist du sicher dass die solo
karriere der richtige schritt war
was gab es denn für eine alternative
denn du hast ja vorher mit bse pons und
kollegen zusammen
ja ich habe mit pelé ein kollaboalbum
groß aber ich schliesse jack ein
kollaboalbum aus ja aber du hast auch
eine eigene truppe gab ganz am anfang
wir haben und der kunst der nation haben
wir uns es verwegen und gehabt aber das
ist ja wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel sagen
wir mal zwei jahren noch ein album
machen würde könnte man es wieder unter
einem corner machen aber das schließlich
aus dass ich
also primär immer so ich bin ein
solokünstler ich kann mich solo am
besten ausdrücken ich muss mich noch
niemand absprechen
ich feiere den bdi aber ich feiere den
nicht oder ich habe bock auf dieses
thema zu behandeln er aber rechtlich
deswegen solo kann man sich als künstler
denke ich am besten ausdrücken
deswegen solo immer primär aber ich
schliesse kollaborationen mit anderen
musikern oder rapper nicht auf